european union leaders may have agreed
to impose sanctions on russia but those
measures stopped shorter blocking russia
from the belgium-based swift global
payment system so banks worldwide use it
to make secure cross-border payments
britain is pushing to block russia but
the u.s and eu are so far opting not to
u.s president joe biden says the
decision could be reconsidered we have
two correspondents following the latest
on the sanctions neve barker is joining
us from london in a moment but first
let's speak to dominic kane who's
joining us from berlin to tell us more
about why the eu
is staying away from blocking russia
from swift dominic
one reason is because there is unease
let's put it no strong more strongly
than that there is unease in several
capitals right now about what that would
mean for their own economies and that's
namely those countries being germany but
also the italians and we understand to a
certain extent the french government has
unease about the thought of
freezing the access to the swift
transaction system which is so vital in
many ways say the german government and
others for german companies who have
trading links with russian business
interests in russia and in germany and
elsewhere in the eu so it's the thought
that actually in doing that in cutting
off russian access to swift that might
also cause such a negative effect on the
economies
in germany in italy and elsewhere in the
eu that's a step that they really aren't
quite prepared right now anyway
to really consider the problem for the
government here is that the political
opposition to the right the
conservatives of the former angler that
angela merkel was in charge of well they
now say well actually we should consider
imposing this freeze freeze on access to
swift for russia one other thing to
think about it's being widely reported
that the eu is going to bring in
personally targeted sanctions against
president putin and foreign minister
lavrov in moscow effectively freezing
their assets well that's one thing that
they could do but what they can't seem
to do right now or at least until now
they haven't indicated they're prepared
to do it is to deny russia writ large
access to the swift transaction system
all right thank you so much dominic kane
reporting from berlin we'll now bring in
new barker uh to nevis joining us from
london so neil britain on the other hand
has been much more vocal in its desire
to see russia banned
from the swift system what's behind that
yeah perceived
perceived disagreement
in ukraine over europe's stance on swift
is only of course adding to the
frustration there in kiev
this is a block of 27 countries and the
uk obviously no longer an eu member but
definitely an ally of the eu's saying
that they cannot agree to step up to the
mark
during ukraine's hour uh of need the
united kingdom though
uh reaffirming that it strongly believes
that more needs to be done and it has
said that it is powerless unilaterally
to force russia out of swift it's an
organization that's based in belgium
there are multiple stakeholders and all
sides essentially have to agree although
the british authorities are continuing
to put pressure on g7 countries and eu
member states to
to essentially do do more but as dominic
raised there there are some big concerns
about cash flow issues of course this
isn't just about money going to russia
it's about money coming from russia to
european countries as well and those
nations that have a bigger stake i
suppose in the russian economy
fear that for instance their creditors
are not going to get their cash back if
all of a sudden russia is kicked out of
swift there are also other concerns that
by kicking russia out of this uh
arrangement that it will force russia
closer towards china that it would
help uh
depower the dollar um at the same time
the united kingdom is keen to see that
channels remain open for at least the
discussion of what might happen to
ukraine when it comes
when it becomes in need i suppose of of
more military support obviously the uk a
nato member is not going to cross that
line it's not going to trigger article 5
uh which would essentially lead to a
protracted conflict across the entire
continent but it has raised the prospect
that militarily arms should be at the
ready potentially in the baltic states
although
talk of exactly how that how those
weapons could potentially reach ukraine
remains a closely guarded secret this is
obviously highly sensitive uh
information given uh the prospects of
what that could mean in terms of a
conflict between nato alliance states
and russia going forward thank you so
much need barker reporting from london